let me ask you the most absurd
question of all that you did not sign up
for but it's
especially i've been hanging out with a
guy named joe rogan recently sure
so it's very important um for from for
me and him to figure this out
if a president because you said you
implied the president is very powerful
if the president shows up and and the
u.s government is in fact in possession
of
aliens alien spacecraft
do you think the president will be told
a more responsible adult historian
question version of that
is is there some things
that the machine of government keeps
secret from the president
or is the president ultimately at the
very center so if you like map out
the set of information and power you
have like cia you have all these
organizations that like
that do the the machinery of government
not just like the passing of bills but
like
uh gaining information homeland security
uh actually like engaging in wars
you know all those kinds of things uh
how
central is the president would the
president know some of the shady things
that are going on
aliens or some kind of
cyber security stuff against russia and
china all those kinds of things
is the president really made aware and
how if so
how nervous does that make you so um
presidents like leaders of any complex
organizations
uh don't know everything that goes on uh
they have to ask the right questions
this is machiavelli
most important thing a leader has to do
is ask the right questions you don't
have to know the answers
that's why you hire smart people but you
have to ask the right questions
so if the president asks uh the us
government those who are responsible for
the aliens or responsible for the cyber
warfare against russia
they will answer honestly they will have
to but they will not volunteer that
information
in all cases so the best way a president
can operate is to have people
around him or her who are not the
traditional policy makers this is where
i think
academic experts are important
suggesting questions
to ask to therefore try to get the
information
it makes me nervous because i think
human nature is such that
the the academics the experts
everybody is almost afraid to ask the
questions
for which the answers might uh
be burdensome yes and so that's right
and you can get into a lot of trouble
not asking it's the old
elephant in the room correct correct
this is exactly right and too often
mediocre leaders
and those who try to protect them try to
shield themselves they don't want to
know certain things
so this is part of what happened with
the use of torture by the united states
which is a war crime
during the war on terror president bush
at times
intentionally did not ask and people
around him prevented him from asking or
discouraged him from asking questions he
should have asked
to know about what was going on and
that's how we ended up
where we did you could say the same
thing about reagan and iran contra i
wonder what it takes to be the kind of
leader
that steps in and asks some difficult
questions so
aliens is one ufo spacecraft right
another one yeah torture is another one
the cia
how much information is being collected
about americans
i can see as a president being very
uncomfortable asking that question
because if the answer is a lot of
information is being collected by of
americans
then you have to be the guy who's lives
with that information
for the rest of your life you have to
walk around
you're probably not going to reform that
system it's very difficult you have to
you probably have to be very picky about
which things you were formed you don't
have much time
it takes a lot of sort of effort to
restructure things
but you nevertheless would have to be
basically lying
to uh to the you know to to
to yourself to others around you about
the unethical things
depends of course what your the ethical
system is
i wonder what it takes to ask those hard
questions
i wonder if how few of us
are can be great leaders like that and i
wonder if our political system
the electoral system such that
makes it likely that such leaders will
come to power
it's hard and you can't ask all the
right questions and there is a legal
hazard if you know things
at certain times but i think you can
back to your point on hiring you can
hire people who will do that in their
domains
and then you have to trust that when
they think it's something that's a
question you need to ask they'll pass
that on to you
this is why it's not a good idea to have
loyalists because loyalists will shield
you from things it's a good idea to have
people of integrity
who you can rely on and who you think
will ask those right questions and then
pass that down through their
organization
you